KEVIN DUNCAN: Hello everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Kevin Duncan.
Today we welcome the
cast of "Fuller House."
So who we have is Candace
Cameron-Bure, Jodie Sweetin,
and Andrew Barber.
[APPLAUSE]
JODIE SWEETIN: Hi.
KEVIN DUNCAN: We've got the
awesome '90s plaid couch here
for you guys.
JODIE SWEETIN: Oh, fantastic.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Look at that.
JODIE SWEETIN: We only
sit on '90s couches.
KEVIN DUNCAN: That's
what we heard.
We had it shipped in from
LA-- San Francisco, excuse me.
So welcome guys.
Welcome to Google.
JODIE SWEETIN: Thank you.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Thank you
ANDREA BARBER: Thank you.
KEVIN DUNCAN: So you guys
are back after 21 years
since you guys went off
the air, and so the show
takes place 29 years.
That said, I love kind of
the intro how they went right
into it that.
So can you just tell
us what you three
are up to after 29 years later.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Well, DJ sadly is widowed,
and-- but she has three kids
and she's a veterinarian.
And is that we're talking about?
The characters right?
It's been a long day.
I've got to pee.
I've been up since 4:00.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JODIE SWEETIN: What have you
been doing like 29 years there?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: I know.
JODIE SWEETIN:
I'm on "The View."
Wow, that's really strange.
Do you need me--
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
I'm setting a great tone
for this interview.
So sorry.
JODIE SWEETIN: I'll be her
interpreter today and I will--
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Thank you.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yes.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Yes, so then so
DJ, that's where she is.
She's a single mom raising
three kids and a working mom,
gets overwhelmed so she invites
her best friend and her sister,
or kind of.
She doesn't invite.
JODIE SWEETIN: Well yeah,
Stephanie, the whole family
is back because Danny is talking
about selling the house, which
is why the original
house is in the show.
Everyone gets to
see that, which I
think is as much of a
character as anybody else.
And they're all there
and Steph, she really
sees her sister struggling,
and overwhelmed,
and needing some help.
And so she kind of gives
up everything and says,
I'm going to move in with you.
And then Kimmy decides
to move in as well and--
KEVIN DUNCAN: I was going
to say she invited herself.
I saw--
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah, she--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JODIE SWEETIN: --in
typical Gibbler style
she invites herself.
ANDREA BARBER: Uninvited.
JODIE SWEETIN: And the frenemy
of relationship continues.
ANDREA BARBER: Yes, yeah.
KEVIN DUNCAN: I got to see
the first few episodes,
and the first episode
was-- really it just
seemed like a mirror image
of the first one with you
three guys in the lead, or
three girls in the lead.
And so can you
talk about the idea
of-- because it's
pretty much a reunion,
but also taking kind of
hey, this is where we were,
and then this is
where we're going.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Yeah,
the pilot episode really
is an ode to all the fans.
It's saying here we are.
We're back together, and
we're giving you everything
we think you're hoping for.
And it's setting up the premise
for what the new show is about,
which is really about us three
women raising these four kids.
So if you haven't heard
already, the original cast
is together for
the first episode.
And then the other characters,
Danny, Jessie, Joey, and Becky,
they pop in and out for some
episodes throughout the series.
But they're not in every
one, because it's revolving
around this new family.
But that--
JODIE SWEETIN: I
think we realized
that we needed to do
that reunion moment,
that people were really
excited for that,
but that "Fuller
House" is a show that
is about much more than that.
But we had to get
it out of the way
so that everyone wouldn't
be like, what happened?
We wanted to see
everybody together.
So we did that.
We gave that to everybody
and then continued on
with the new series.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Well, it was
great because the first episode
happened and I was like,
oh this is very familiar
and it's great to
see all you guys.
And then it was literally
the second episode you guys,
it was really
different, actually,
because it actually went
in different directions.
And Andrea I love--
we all love Kimmy.
We all love Kimmy.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
We love Kimmy.
ANDREA BARBER: I love Kimmy.
KEVIN DUNCAN: And
I love the fact
that-- it was so fun because
I just remember Kimmy always
being there, but I
actually watching back
in the first few
seasons prepping
for this, Kimmy's character
was just kind of this side
character and popped
in and out, and then
got more and more in
the later episodes.
So to have you now
as a leading-- one
of the leading ladies in this.
This is fantastic.
ANDREA BARBER: It's thrilling.
It's overwhelming.
And Kimmy is so excited to
finally move inside the house.
It was her childhood home,
too, even though nobody really
wanted her there.
But she's finally home
and it's exciting,
and it's so cool to be
here with these women.
We're just having
such a blast together.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
It was hysterical
because-- I mean we've
been acting since the show.
Andrea retired from acting
right after the show.
And then we get on the
set and we're like,
oh, we get to revive
these characters.
And you kind of wonder,
how's it going to be.
And Andrea literally,
she gets on the set
and she gets a
script in her hand,
and she just like morphs
into Kimmy Gibbler,
like without missing a beat.
It was, it's-- I love it.
JODIE SWEETIN: It
was hysterical, yeah.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: I love it.
ANDREA BARBER: Kimmy Gibbler
has been hibernating inside
of me for the last 20
years, and I finally
get to unleash her to the world.
It's great.
JODIE SWEETIN: I mean
she's hysterical.
It's every time Kimmy is on
screen I just-- I die laughing.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Well, your
backstory is very interesting,
because you have an
estranged husband who
pops into the episodes
here and there.
But were there any
other ideas in terms
of what her backstory
was going to be
and what she was
going to be doing?
Because you're an
entrepreneur, you're
an event planner in the--
ANDREA BARBER: Yeah, Kimmy
is now a party planner.
s she takes her
parties very seriously.
But yeah, Jeff Franklin, our
creator and executive producer,
he and I talked a
lot about what--
who is modern Kimmy Gibbler now?
And one of the ideas
we threw around
was maybe she should be an
interpreter for the United
Nations, and so she comes in
speaking all these languages.
And everyone's like,
where did that come from.
But we finally
settled on-- you know,
you've got to stay true to the
original eccentric characters.
So she's a party planner.
She's still zany.
She's still living in the
'90s, but she's a modern woman.
She's a single mom and
she's helping out DJ,
but DJ and Stephanie are
helping out her, too.
JODIE SWEETIN: She plans
great parties, though.
There's several parties in the
first season of "Fuller House"
and they're all
Gibbler-style parties.
KEVIN DUNCAN: And
you're also a DJ?
JODIE SWEETIN: I am a DJ.
I am DJ Tanner.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
She stole my name.
Who does that?
KEVIN DUNCAN: It's awesome.
I love that.
JODIE SWEETIN: I'm DJ Tanner.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
It's so wrong.
JODIE SWEETIN: It's
kind of awesome.
KEVIN DUNCAN: So
that's your career now?
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah,
Steph has been a DJ.
She's been traveling the world.
She's been living sort of an
unattached-- not irresponsible,
but not really a
tied down lifestyle.
And she comes home.
And she was in London.
Didn't think she was
going to make it,
and she comes home and
decides that she really needs
to be there for her sister.
But Steph's character
has been having--
KEVIN DUNCAN: Kimmy.
ANDREA BARBER: That was
Dave Coulier farting off--
Don't mind that.
JODIE SWEETIN: What happened?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
You guys have no idea.
Who is that? [INAUDIBLE].
JODIE SWEETIN: What's going on?
Is someone--
CANDACE CAMERON BURE: It's
starting to turn into a beat.
JODIE SWEETIN: Right?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: DJ
Tanner, drop the beat.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Come
on, drop the beat.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Is it mine?
KEVIN DUNCAN: It's Candace.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Should I turn this off then?
KEVIN DUNCAN: There we go.
JODIE SWEETIN: There you
go, just yank it off.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
All righty, we'll
put it right here.
KEVIN DUNCAN: I'll take that.
There we go.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: I'll
hide it behind the pillow.
KEVIN DUNCAN:
Google, technology.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah,
you guys really
should work on that
aspect of your--
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN DUNCAN: And
so you were saying.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
What was I saying?
KEVIN DUNCAN: I'm
not sure anymore.
JODIE SWEETIN: I was saying.
You interrupted.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Sorry, whack-a-mole.
OK.
JODIE SWEETIN: Oh,
it's been a long day.
No, Stephanie, yeah, she's
been having a lot of fun.
And so she comes
back and really steps
into a position of
helping her sister out.
And it's great because Stephanie
gets to kind of transform
in those first few episodes to
this person who doesn't really
want to be grounded anywhere to
showing back up for her sister.
And then Steph and Kimmy
have this amazing frenemy
relationship, where they sort
of battle but love each other
and really-- and
Stephanie knows that Kimmy
has been there for her sister.
And that means a lot to her.
KEVIN DUNCAN: For sure,
and I love how it really
tackles more adult themes.
Because it was
interesting watching that,
too, while obviously
you guys were kids
and you had no storylines.
But was it interesting
and fun, and what
was the process of coming
up with adult storylines?
Were you guys influencing
that with your real life,
or what was that process?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Well, all three of us
are moms in real life.
And so we did meet
with all of the writers
and we're talking about
our parenting styles
and giving them stories
out of our real life
that have happened.
So I know they've plucked things
from that to also form them
into our characters.
That's a fun aspect of the
show is that the three of us,
as our characters,
parent very differently.
And so we fill in the gaps.
Where there's a
weakness, there's
a strength from another.
But as far as being the
adults on the show and all
those storylines, I
mean I think we're
just happy we don't have to
go to school on our breaks
like when we were kids.
I mean it's fun to
drive the show this time
as the women and not the kids.
But we love working with
the new kids on the show
and it gives them this-- we
have the most unique perspective
in that sense, that we can give
to them everything that we've
already gone through.
And at the same time,
not only teach them,
but we can also say, hey,
stop complaining because we've
already done this too.
We understand and we get it.
KEVIN DUNCAN: And so you
guys are on Netflix now,
which is phenomenal.
And Stamos seemed to be the guy
who was pushing for this a lot
and always bringing it back up.
And he's a producer I think
on the series as well.
So has it been-- it's
great to see it on Netflix
and has it been also
different in that you don't
have to really be in
the network guidelines
and you don't have to adhere
to 22 minutes and stuff.
And has that changed
too much or--
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah,
I mean, I think
it's this is sort of uncharted
territory for us as far as
how to do a sitcom within a
much looser framework, which
is a real benefit
to being on Netflix.
We can make the shows
a little bit longer.
So if it's 26 minutes, it's
like, all right that's fine.
We don't have to panic
and cut a bunch of stuff
that we think is really good.
We're not beholden
to finding out
what our ratings are
every week and panicking
if something goes up or down.
And it gives us a lot
of freedom to really
be able to do a show that the
fans love and the fans want.
And I think that that was why
this has been so immensely
popular and why it
had such a success
at coming back in the first
place is that the fans love it.
ANDREA BARBER: It's a great
partnership with Netflix,
too, because of the
way "Full House" fans
watch "Full House." "Full House"
has never been off the air
in 30 years.
And it's on 4, 5, 6, 7 times
every night at Nick at Night,
so people have already
been binge watching
"Full House" for a long time.
And so when it's
released tomorrow
at 12:01 AM on Netflix, you
can just have an all-nighter.
You can watch every episode
you want, just all in a row.
Or you can space them out if
you want to savor each episode.
KEVIN DUNCAN: And you guys
have so many characters
that come back.
Steve is back for the first
episode, and obviously
Bob Saget and everyone.
And so was there a character
from the old show that you
wanted to bring back
and you couldn't?
JODIE SWEETIN: I want to
bring back Gia, who was--
KEVIN DUNCAN: That was actually
a social media question.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah, I
want to bring her back.
And there's been
discussions about it,
so we'll see what happens.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Season 2.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Wasn't she
a really bad influence on you?
Why do you want to bring
her back, Stephanie?
Making more bad decisions.
JODIE SWEETIN: You haven't
been a part of my life, DJ.
You don't know what's going on.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Only
because you stayed away.
JODIE SWEETIN: [SIGHS]
We've had this talk before.
We're not doing it here.
We're not doing it here, DJ.
CANDACE CAMERON BURE: Are
we taking this too far?
KEVIN DUNCAN: You're
being very rude.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: I think
do we collectively want--
BOTH: Kathy Santoni.
ANDREA BARBER: I want to know
if she's still throwing pool
parties with her big boobs.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: She's
like the girl when you go back
to your high school
reunion and you
want to see if she's
still all that that she
was in high school, or
you can be like ha ha.
KEVIN DUNCAN: And I read you
guys actually brought your kids
back on set and stuff.
So what was their experience
like seeing their parents back
at it?
JODIE SWEETIN: My
kids had a blast.
They thought it was really fun.
The first couple tapings
they were super into it,
and then they just wanted to
go hang out in my trailer.
But they, I mean they loved it.
They loved seeing my
"Full House" family
and watching mommy
work and have fun.
And you know my youngest
daughter Beatrix, she's five.
And that's how old I was when
I started doing the show, which
is just mind-blowing to me
that all this time later I
have my own kids and they
get to be there witnessing
me doing what I love.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Yeah.
What's great about the show as
well, because I mean it does
take off in the second episode
and start becoming different.
But you guys still
keep the same format.
It's the same multi-camera
and everything.
I mean was there any
discussion once you went there,
because everything seems
to be in documentary style
this day and age.
Was there any kind of
pressure or felt like, oh
maybe we should go to
this or do we really want
to keep it as multi-camera?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
I only knew
it to be in the original
sitcom for camera style.
Did you hear
anything before that?
JODIE SWEETIN: No, I don't so.
I know there had been
some discussion of it
back and forth as to
what they wanted to do,
but I know that Netflix
really strongly wanted
to bring this genre
back and reintroduce it
sort of to audiences,
and really make
it popular with
their family viewing
with their multi-camera.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Yeah, and I
think it's important
that we're not trying
to break into something new.
This is a show that people
have loved for 30 years.
And so if the format was
changed too dramatically,
people would say this
isn't what I remember.
This isn't even
what I'm wanting.
So it is for that
fan that I think
a lot of the people
that are wanting
to watch the show again, whether
they were kids or the same ages
as us have grown up.
They're now maybe they're
parents, maybe you have kids,
and they don't make shows
in that format anymore.
And it's like you
want to go, I want
to have the same
experience with my child
that I had with my
parents growing up.
And that's why I think it
works in its original format.
KEVIN DUNCAN: For sure.
And was there any--
what was the toughest
part or the scariest
part just about getting
this back together and putting
this on the air online?
ANDREA BARBER: We wanted
to do the legacy proud,
and we didn't want to do
a cheesy reunion movie.
There have been some of
those done in the past.
And we didn't want people
to make fun of this reunion.
So yeah, we wanted
to do it right.
We wanted the right
people involved,
so getting Jeff Franklin,
our original creator,
and Bob Boyett, our original
executive producer involved,
was critical.
And once they were on board
I felt a lot more confident
that this was a show that
was going to be done right.
It's not just a cheesy
movie, it's not a reboot,
it's not "Full House 2.0."
It really is a continuation of a
story that started 30 years ago
when we were little kids.
KEVIN DUNCAN: That's great.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Well said.
KEVIN DUNCAN: We're
going to start
taking audience questions
in a few minutes,
if you guys want
to start lining up.
We do have some questions
from social media,
though, that we want to get to.
Some of this is from Twitter.
Some of this is G+.
Some of this is from
our audience here.
Favorite direct reference to the
old show that we can look for.
JODIE SWEETIN:
Yeah, there's a lot.
I mean the old
catchphrases are back.
I think that fans
will be pleasantly
surprised at the amount
of Easter eggs hidden
throughout the show of reverence
to the original series.
KEVIN DUNCAN: You brought
back the blue couch I saw.
JODIE SWEETIN: The
original blue couch.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: It
really is the original.
It's been in storage, no
joke, and the two blue chairs.
JODIE SWEETIN: The
two blue chairs.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
And so original
that Andrew was allergic to
it and was coughing every time
she'd be in the living room.
ANDREA BARBER: I only figured
out after the first week.
I thought how come every time I
have a scene in the living room
I have an asthma attack.
I can't say my lines like this.
And Jodie's actually the
one that figured it out.
She said, you're
allergic to the couch.
And I walked over
there and sat down,
and I felt this
little puff of dust.
You know maybe it
was just in my mind.
But yeah, I was
allergic, so I had
to go out and get it cleaned
organically and everything.
No problems after
that first week.
KEVIN DUNCAN: But the whole
set was rebuilt, right?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Yes.
From scratch and from
photos because they
lost the original
blueprints of the set.
Yeah, it was quite the task.
JODIE SWEETIN:
Yeah, like two weeks
before we got picked up
officially they destroyed
the blueprints
thinking like, we're
never going to need these.
And then like it was within a
few weeks they went and like,
oh you know what we need, and
they went and they were like,
oh we just destroyed those.
So they had to go back and watch
hundreds of hours of footage.
KEVIN DUNCAN: You
didn't, just them.
JODIE SWEETIN: No,
no, I was actually
not out there hammering
the set together by myself.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Andrea, where
can we get your bacon and eggs
scarf and donut purse?
ANDREA BARBER: And I
got that question a lot.
The show hasn't even
been released yet
and I'm already getting
questions about Kimmy Gibbler
accessories, so there might
be a Kimmy Gibbler gift
shop at some point.
I don't even know.
Our wardrobe stylist
is so fantastic
and I don't know how she
found all of these things.
But I hear from fans that
the bacon and egg scarf
is available on Etsy somewhere.
And the donut purse is actually
a Betsey Johnson purse.
And when "Fuller
House" posted some
of those episodic still photos
of me wearing the donut purse,
Betsey Johnson herself
actually chimed in and was
like, hey that's my purse.
Thanks, Kimmy, for wearing it.
Yeah, it was pretty cool.
KEVIN DUNCAN: And DJ, this
was-- at first thing people
were shocked when they
heard that you were going
to be a widow,
because everyone just
assumed you were with
Steve, but Steve is actually
alive and well.
So why didn't you marry Steve?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Well, aren't you happy
I didn't marry Steve?
Because that would stink.
You'd never see him again.
Or he'd be dead!
KEVIN DUNCAN: Bad question.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
No, I think
it gives everyone hope
that I did marry him,
because now he is back.
And yeah, we wanted that.
I don't know.
Well, I do know why--
no, maybe I don't
know why it didn't work out.
JODIE SWEETIN: I don't
know what you're--
ANDREA BARBER: You
broke up with him.
JODIE SWEETIN: Oh,
why did you do that?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Why
did I break up with him.
JODIE SWEETIN: He
got married first.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Well,
he did get married first,
but I broke up with
him on the mountains.
DJ just wasn't ready for that
relationship in high school.
ANDREA BARBER: And he
was moving off to college
and you guys were going
in separate directions.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: They
know much more about DJ's life
than I do, apparently.
KEVIN DUNCAN: So we'll take
our first audience question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name's Lisa, and I just
want to say you all
look so amazingly fit.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Oh, thank you.
ANDREA BARBER: We
like you, Lisa.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I am so
impressed, and I'm enthusiast.
So I was wondering--
JODIE SWEETIN: Black pants,
they're really slimming.
It's fantastic.
AUDIENCE: I mean you
guys must exercise.
And I just wonder what
do you do and how do you
fit it into your
clearly very busy lives?
ANDREA BARBER: You're
the fitness guru so--
JODIE SWEETIN:
You've run marathons.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: I know
and she's a marathon runner.
Tell them how many marathons
and halves you've run.
ANDREA BARBER: OK,
I just finished
my fourth full marathon, LA
Marathon like 11 days ago,
so my feet barely
recovered in time
to put on these heels,
and 25 half marathons.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Amazing.
And then I roped her into
a few races, the Spartan
or the Tough Mudder mud runs.
ANDREA BARBER: Camp
Pendleton Mud Run.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Yeah,
I like strength stuff.
I workout about
five days a week,
and I travel every single week.
I commute LA to New
York, because I'm
co-hosting "The View"
here in New York,
but my family is in LA.
So it's a struggle,
but I go after work.
We're actually going
to workout at 7 o'clock
tonight, because I just
feel better if I do it.
JODIE SWEETIN: I'm the
lazy one of the group.
I only work out like three or
four days a week apparently.
And I love bacon so yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, so first of
all, thank you for coming.
This is a childhood
dream fulfilled.
Jodie, this question
is for you and it's
going to be a weird one.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Try me.
AUDIENCE: My favorite
GIF that I've
been using for since GIFs
were invented is how rude.
Can we get a
reenactment of how rude?
JODIE SWEETIN: How rude.
[APPLAUSE]
And that's totally
not a weird question,
and that is one that
I get all the time,
which is a huge compliment.
And the fact that, yeah it
was like the number seven
GIF of 2015.
I was like score.
I think I've even beat
out Kanye, which yeah,
but I think it was
like misspelled Kanye.
But still I'll take it.
I'll take it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi guys, also
huge dream come true.
But I wanted to
know, so having known
Danny Tanner as
my childhood life,
and then sort of getting to know
Bob Saget the comedian, very
different people.
I wanted to know
as kids on the set,
like which guy
did you guys know.
ANDREA BARBER: All of the above.
AUDIENCE: But you
were really young.
Like how did that--
I guess as you
got older did it more come out?
ANDREA BARBER: Yeah,
Bob reined it in.
The guys reined--
they knew there
were little kids on
the set, and our moms
were on the set
with us every day.
By law they were
required to be there.
So the moms every once and a
while would make their rounds
and be like, OK boys,
let's watch the language.
The guys did rein it in.
JODIE SWEETIN: I actually
went to the Laugh Factory
with Bob when I was
about nine years old
and watched him do a set.
I'm not kidding.
Not intentionally,
I was, I would
spend-- he had three daughters
that I was very close with,
and as I was spending
the weekend at his house
and he's like, OK wait.
Hold on, we've got
to-- I'm doing a set.
I'm like, all right cool.
He's like your mom is probably
going to kill me, but whatever.
And I was like it's
fine, we're good.
You know I'm 9 or
whatever, 10 or 9.
And I sat on the back
speakers in the back
of the Laugh Factory.
I got to give him his
little five minute
warning with the
flashlight and tell him
it was time to
get off the stage.
And it was kind of
awesome, it was hilarious.
And I mean I have a great
love for stand-up comedy,
and I think it really
came from those two guys.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Growing
up with them, yeah, so
did that really shape
your guys' sense of humor,
because you guys were so young
when you were on the show?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
That's why I needed Jesus.
JODIE SWEETIN: It's
why I needed drugs.
[LAUGHTER]
Hey, look if you can't joke
about it, you know what I mean.
KEVIN DUNCAN: There's
no segue here.
There's no transition.
JODIE SWEETIN: No, there
isn't, but you know what.
I mean I have a pretty dark
and crazy sense of humor,
and I do think that I
gained a real appreciation
for the darker humors
from those guys,
because they're pretty dark.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Mine too.
Bob shaped my sense of
humor, to which I had
to turn it off and reshape it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Misty and my
heart's racing, which is funny.
But as you can see, we're
in a corporate environment
but I did a tribute to you
three by crimping my hair today.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Yeah, I love it.
AUDIENCE: This is not--
this is not natural.
KEVIN DUNCAN: She was the
first one in the room today,
by the way.
AUDIENCE: I could
kind of see Candace
staring at me being like, I
wonder if that's her real hair.
So at Google we're taught
to take one risk every day
that makes us really
uncomfortable.
We call it
uncomfortably excited.
So my question is would you
make a Googler's dream come true
and take a picture with
me crimping DJ's hair?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Yes, totally.
JODIE SWEETIN: That is awesome.
AUDIENCE: I found this,
which is the three of you.
JODIE SWEETIN: Aw.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
It's a trading card.
AUDIENCE: I'm going
to need that back.
[LAUGHTER]
JODIE SWEETIN: Oh my God!
AUDIENCE: I want you
guys to feel very--
JODIE SWEETIN: Your necklace
is fabulous by the way.
I love that.
It's amazing.
AUDIENCE: It's Google colors.
JODIE SWEETIN: It's really cute.
AUDIENCE: I actually
thought what I'd
wear to complement you guys.
I want you to be very jealous.
JODIE SWEETIN: I was
worried about what
you were going to wear at home.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: She
is directing this thing.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREA BARBER: She's
got a crimping iron
and she's about
to touch her head.
Be careful. listen to her.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Should I be scared?
AUDIENCE: It's not
on, don't worry.
ANDREA BARBER: It's
not plugged in.
AUDIENCE: Ready?
We're smiling right there.
Thank you.
JODIE SWEETIN: You
are so welcome.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
JODIE SWEETIN: That was awesome.
The fact that you
have a crimping iron
impresses me greatly.
AUDIENCE: It took 45
minutes to warm up.
JODIE SWEETIN: Wow,
and that, yeah,
that was quick in like 1987.
ANDREA BARBER: That was the
best question on the press
tour so far, hands down.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Follow that up.
Follow that.
JODIE SWEETIN: It's just
going to get weirder.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
I have two things.
One, you three are all
incredibly gorgeous.
JODIE SWEETIN: Thank you.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And two, I have a
question for the majestic human
being named Candace.
JODIE SWEETIN: Oh, look at
you, majestic like an eagle.
AUDIENCE: I know that you were
on "Dancing with the Stars"
and that is one of my
all-time favorite shows.
I was wondering how your
experience there was?
Did you like it more than
"Full House" or equally?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Oh--
ANDREA BARBER: Pressure.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
No pressure.
JODIE SWEETIN: [CLEARING THROAT]
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: But
nothing beats out you two.
JODIE SWEETIN: OK, good.
Just checking.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: It was
one of the greatest experiences
of my life, so much so that
I wrote my third book using
"Dancing with the Stars"
as the framework for it.
So it's called
"Dancing Through Life,"
but I use that framework to talk
about courage and conviction.
Because like you, stepping--
yeah, crimped hair.
I'm talking to you, and you're
like tweeting out right now.
[LAUGHTER]
That was like my brave
moment to step out
on a stage and dance,
which I've never
danced before on live
television every week.
And I wanted to throw up every
week, because it was so scary.
AUDIENCE: You were
great, by the way.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Thank you.
So it really, it
changed me a lot
and it gave me a lot of courage.
And I take a lot more
risks now, and I'm not
scared because I got
through that process.
I enjoyed it, but it was scary.
I loved it, though.
ANDREA BARBER: And she killed
it every week until the finals.
I'm so proud of you.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Thanks Kimmy.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I have two
feelings questions for you.
One is that for so many of us
this show is very nostalgic.
So I was wondering what it
was like for you guys, what
it felt like to sort of step
back into that nostalgia.
Because I think for us
watching this show is going
to be as close as we can
get, but you guys almost
went back in time, and so I was
wondering what that was like.
And also, how did it feel when
they changed your bedrooms?
And you guys
basically, when they--
in the original when they,
for me it was a little bit
traumatic when they--
[LAUGHTER]
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
I'm with you on that.
I was like what are
these orange walls?
Where's my geometric
shaped bedspread?
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah,
remember that red bed?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
I know, kind of sad.
But we had to move on.
JODIE SWEETIN: I think we--
when did we change that, too?
It was like the sixth season.
I don't know, I felt like
it was fourth, fifth?
I don't even remember.
Anyway, it was traumatic.
We were sad, but
we did have input
as to what our rooms were going
to look like, at least I did.
Did they give you input?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
What back in the day?
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
I thought she
was talking about the new one.
No?
JODIE SWEETIN: I thought
she was talking about.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
seen the new bedrooms.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
OK, whatevs.
It's a long day people, OK.
AUDIENCE: I meant when you
guys were like 10 and 6.
JODIE SWEETIN: When
we were little.
CANDACE CAMERON
BURE: I'm so ditzy.
JODIE SWEETIN: I'm sure now
it wouldn't be traumatic.
We know it's a set.
It's a thing.
It's OK.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
I was traumatic-- I was
traumatized this time around.
Is that wrong?
JODIE SWEETIN: They haven't
changed your bedroom.
It's like you're not
even in your own bedroom.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Can you scratch my back?
I just want to be cuddled.
We're turning into children.
KEVIN DUNCAN: This has
gotten weird, yeah.
It's gotten really weird.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
We get a little loopy.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah, we did.
By the end of the
day it's weird.
It's really weird.
No, but I don't think it
was-- I mean we had fun.
We got to have input.
They were always really
great at including the kids
in some of the stuff
like that that went on.
So we got to talk about what
we-- what posters we wanted
and what we wanted our
rooms to look like.
And stepping back in,
as far as nostalgia
goes, to stand on the set
and work with these people
that we walked away from that
home of ours 21 years ago
was an incredible experience.
And I don't think that it's-- I
don't think anything really can
fully prepare you for what
that feels like to stand there
in the kitchen with these people
after you know 21 years ago
really tearfully saying goodbye
and closing the door on that
moment.
KEVIN DUNCAN: And one final one.
AUDIENCE: This is crazy.
I think everyone in this room
is geeking out right now,
and I've never seen
anything like it.
But my question is,
speaking of '90s nostalgia,
I work for Google
Music, and so I'm
dying to know what each of
your favorite '90s song is.
ANDREA BARBER: Well, we dance
to mine on the pilot episode.
You can see it in the trailer
right now. [SINGING] It's
the right stuff, oh, oh, oh, oh.
BOTH: Oh, oh, oh.
ANDREA BARBER: Yeah she's--
crimped hair is dancing.
BOTH: The right stuff.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: I got to--
it might be "You Oughta Know"
by Alanis Morisette.
JODIE SWEETIN: Oh,
that's awesome.
KEVIN DUNCAN: That's awesome.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
I love Alanis.
JODIE SWEETIN: God, I don't
even know if I could pick one,
but I'm a '90s hip hop girl
so that was kind of what
I grew up with and liked.
I was never-- the boy band thing
wasn't my, wasn't my steeze.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
"Baby's Got Back"?
JODIE SWEETIN: No, more like
Tupac, Biggie, like that.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Oh, that's me.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah, yeah.
Although I did-- and I think
actually that song was earlier,
like late '80s, because
I seem to remember--
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Oh was it?
JODIE SWEETIN: No, "Baby's
Got Back," Sir Mix-A-Lot.
That was later, never mind.
We're not going to go into a
full dissection of '90s hip
hop right now, but yeah.
KEVIN DUNCAN: This one is too
excited to not ask, so quickly.
AUDIENCE: I am,
just like everyone.
JODIE SWEETIN: We'll shut up
and let you ask and answer
the question.
We have too much,
but we're just going
to actually sit here
when everyone leaves
and keep talking.
AUDIENCE: Cool, well,
thank you for letting
me ask my question, and again,
totally awesome moment for us
right now.
This one is kind of awkward,
but I wanted to ask it.
I was a little bit
young for the show,
and I actually called
the show Michelle,
because I loved her
character so much.
And so it was kind
of sad for me to see
that Mary-Kate and Ashley
weren't going to be returning,
so I just wanted to see
what your take on that was.
ANDREA BARBER: Yeah,
Mary-Kate and Ashley
have moved on from the show.
They've moved on from Hollywood.
They're not in front
of cameras anymore,
and we totally respect
their decision to do that.
But I think we get
that question a lot
from the press about why
aren't they coming back.
But I think once you start to
watch the first few episodes
of "Fuller House," you'll see
that it is a very full house.
We have even more characters
than we did originally,
if you can believe it.
And so we reference Michelle's
character on the show
and she's still a
part of the family,
but I don't think the character
will be missed because there's
so much packed into this show.
AUDIENCE: And I still
love you guys, too.
I just happened to call it
Michelle when I was little,
but you guys were great.
JODIE SWEETIN:
I've heard actually
that in Japan they call the
show Michelle, strangely enough.
KEVIN DUNCAN: There we go.
ANDREA BARBER: There you go.
JODIE SWEETIN: No,
I'm not kidding.
I've heard that that's like a
common thing nickname for "Full
House" in Japan is Michelle.
AUDIENCE: Well thanks, guys.
KEVIN DUNCAN: But I think
also not having Michelle
brought your character a little
more forward too, Andrea.
I think having the balance
of you three has been just,
it's been so fun and
so interesting to see.
JODIE SWEETIN: Yeah,
I think it's great.
We've got this
sister relationship,
and she and Steph are--
ANDREA BARBER: Hey.
JODIE SWEETIN: --battling.
KEVIN DUNCAN: It's perfect.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Clearly, we love each other.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Well, thank you
guys so much for being here.
So let's thank them
for being here guys.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Thank you guys for coming.
JODIE SWEETIN:
Thank you so much.
CANDACE CAMERON BURE:
We appreciate it.
KEVIN DUNCAN: So you can catch
"Fuller House" on Netflix
February 26 at 12:01.
So check it out guys, all the
episodes will be on there.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREA BARBER: Woo.
KEVIN DUNCAN: Thank
you guys for being here
and we'll see next time.
JODIE SWEETIN: Thank you, guys.
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]